اهلا بكم اندلعت مواجهه متفرقه بين
الفلسطينيين وقوات الاحتلال في احياء عده
في القدس المحتله في الوقت الذي اتخذت فيه
الحكومه الاسرائيليه قرارا باغلاق الحرم
القدسيه الشريف قبل ان تقرر اعاده فتحه مع
فجر يوم الجمعه نتوقف مع هذا الخبر
لنناقشه في محورين ما اسباب هذا التصعيد
الاسرائيلي في القدس
وهل من سبيل لاي جهد دولي لوضع حد له
قررت الحكومه الاسرائيليه اعاده فتح الحرم
القدسي الشريف في وجه المسلمين واليهود
بعد ان كانت قد قررت اغلاقها هذه الخطوه
من نتنياهو جاءت في اعقاب محاوله اغتيال
الحاخام المتطرف لهدى هذا التصعيد
الاسرائيلي ياتي وسط حديثا عن خطه لتقسيم
الحرم القدسي زمنيا ومكانيا بين المسلمين
واليهود على غرار ما حصل بالنسبه لتقسيم
المسجد الابراهيمي من قبل الاسرائيليين
وذلك في مدينه الخليل
ليس بالهتاف وحده يقاوم الفلسطينيون تهويد
القدس
تتعرض مدينتهم لما هو اسوا من الاحتلال
يتعمد غلاه اليدين الاسرائيلي زياره الحرم
القدسي يسعون الى تحويل سلوان الى حي
يهودي خالص للاطباق على الحرم والاسوء
فلسطينيا خطط اسرائيليه لتكرار سيناريو
الحرم الابراهيمي اي تقسيم الحرم زمانيا
ومكانيا عبر تخصيص اماكن وايام منفصله
لصلوات المسلمين واليهود في المسجد الاقصى
ما يعني عمليا ابتلاعه بعد تهويده يرفض
الفلسطينيون ما يراد ان يكون قدرا لهم
يشتبكون مع جنود الاحتلال يتصدون لمساعي
غلاه اليمين فيتعرض احدهم وهو يقود حمله
تدعو للسماح لليهود بالصلاه في الحرم
القدسي لمحاوله اغتيال فتغلق اسرائيل
الحرم وتلك ذروه في التصعيد تجعل
الفلسطينيين امام خيار وحيد انتفاضه في
القدس لا تبقي ولا تذر
بدات الحمله باغتيال الفتى محمد ابو خطير
حرقا وتوسعت وتصاعدت بالتزامن خطط
استيطانيه كان اخرها مشروع لبناء الف وحده
استيطانيه جديده في القدس وبينما هو ماض
فيما يريد لا يلقي نتنياهو بالا حتى
لاصوات داخل حكومته بان من شان ذلك زياده
التوتر مع الامريكيين والاتحاد الاوروبي
معا ازمه لم تعد صامته على الضفه
الاوروبيه على الاقل وتجاهد كي لا تخرج
للعلن في شقها الامريكي تنحصر في تسريبات
صحفيه يتم نفيها لاحقا بعد ان تحقق هدفها
على ما يبدو اخرها هجوم حاد من مسؤول
امريكي لم تذكر مجله اطلانتيك اسمه يصف
نتنياهو بالجبان والتافه وبحسب تصريحات
الرجل فان نتنياهو لن يفعل اي شيء للتواصل
الى تسويه مع الفلسطينيين ليست لديه
الشجاعه ولا يعنيه شيء سوى حمايه نفسه من
الهزيمه السياسيه تنفذ تصريحات لكن ذلك لا
ينفي ان علاقه الرجل باوباما هي الاسوا
بين رئيس امريكي ورئيس وزراء اسرائيلي
اختلف حول ايران والملف الفلسطيني وبدا ان
نتنياهو يتصرف وفقا لتسريبات صحفيه بغطرسه
لا تليق بدوله صغيره تقتات على الحمايه
الامريكيه بل كرئيس وزراء دوله عظمى يريد
من حليفته وهي الكبرى في العالم الرضوخه
وتنفيذ ما يملى عليها وتؤمر
معنا في هذه الحلقه من غزه الكاتب والمحلل
السياسي مصطفى الصواف من القدس الدكتور
الداده باردو استاذ الدراسات الشرق
الاوسطيه في الجامعه العبريه ومن واشنطن
الكاتب المتخصص في السياسه الخارجيه
الامريكيه سعيد رفقات اهلا بضيوفنا جميعا
نبدا بالدكتور الداد باردو
هل من تفسير لكل هذه الخطوات الاسرائيليه
الاخيره في القدس المحتله
ليست هناك خطوات اسرائيليه كان اعلان عن
اغلاق الحرم القبطيه الشريف للصلاه بسبب
توتر ولكن كما استمعنا تم العدول عن هذه
الخطوه منذ هجوم الاردن على اسرائيل عام
الهجوم الاردني الهجوم الاردني على
اسرائيل عفوا الهجوم الاردني على اسرائيل
عام 67 نعم نعم يعني هذا بين قوسين
من الاردن
من قضائف المدفعيه الاردنيه
بعد ان دخلت اسرائيل الى البلده القديمه
فقدتها هذا اليوم سلمت الحرم القدسي
الشريف الى الوقف الاسلامي وما زالت بعد
ذلك الاردن ثم سلطه الفلسطينيه بمشاركه
الاردن والمغرب والتركية ايضا
باداره امور
الحرم القدسي الشريف وكانت الاذاعه
الاسرائيليه تبص ببث مباشر دائما الخطبه
من من مسجد الاقصى المبارك
فحقيقه الامر ان على هذا جبل كان في ما
مضى البيت
مقتص الاول والثاني والثالث ايضا
اسمح لي دكتور برده لان يعني المجال اسمح
لي سيد بردو اسمح لي حتى لا حتى بعد اذنك
يعني حتى لا نغوص كثيرا في جوانب تاريخيه
انا قصدت بالاجراءات الاسرائيليه ليس فقط
اغلاق المسجد وانما اكثر من الف وحده
استيطانيه زياره رئيس بلديه
القدس الى الحرم القدسي مجموعه اجراءات
امنيه مشدده اتخذها المجلس الوزاري ولهذا
هذا هو مكان قصدي واسمح لي ان انقل نفس
السؤال الى سيد مصطفى الصواف عن طبيعه
نظره الفلسطينيين لهذه الاجراءات
الاسرائيليه في القدس
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
اعتقد التي تمارس من
قبل الص في مدينه القدس هو جريمه حرب ضد
الانسانيه لا يعقل ان يكون هناك مكانا
مقدسا او مسجدا للصلاه او كنس او كنيسه
يتم اغلاقها بهذه الطريقه ما يسعى
الاحتلال الصهيوني اليه هو محاوله تقسيم
مدينه القدس زماننا ومكانا ما بين
الفلسطينيين او المسلمين وبين اليهود وكل
ما تحدث به ضيفك الكريم هي مجموعه من
المغالطات التاريخيه والتراثيه حتى هذه
اللحظه لم يثبت لليهود ان لهم مكانا في
مدينه القدس ولو حتى ولو حجرا واحدا وهذا
بكل الدراسات التراثيه والتراثات الاثريه
التي اجريت سواء من خبراء حتى يهود
واسرائيليين او من خبراء دوليين فلذلك هذا
مكان خالص للمسلمين وانا اعتقد ان هذا
اعتداء كبير سيحرك مشاعر الشعب الفلسطيني
باتجاه مواجهه هذه العمليه التي عليها
الاحتلال تمهيدا للوصول الى الهدف المنشود
وهو العمل على هدم المسجد الاقصى لاقامه
ما يسمى بالهيكل المزعوم لليهود فيه وهذه
ربما هي خطوات تكون الاولى في اتجاه هذا
التقسيم الزماني والمكاني الذي سيؤدي الى
هذه الخطوه النهائيه التي يسعى اليها يهود
في مدينه القدس وانا اعتقد ان هذا سيجر
المنطقه جميعها الى حرب دينيه ما بين
المسلمين وما بين اليهود وهذا
يعني
عندما عدت الاجراءات الاسرائيليه في القدس
بالطبع لابد من الاشاره الى ما وقع
للشاب معتز حجازي الذي قتل كما تقول اسرته
بدم بارد بعد مداهمه بيته على كل عندما
نتحدث عن هذا الوضع سيد سعيد عريقات
الولايات المتحده سارعت للطلب باعاده فتح
المسجد الاقصى في وجه المسلمين ويبدو ان
ربما القرار الاسرائيلي جاء نتيجه هذه
الدعوه الامريكيه على ما يبدو على الاقل
من الناحيه الزمنيه هل هناك انزعاج
بتقديرك ملكي مما يجري الان في القدس
بكل تاكيد انا اعتقد ان هناك انزعاج
امريكي من التصرفات الاسرائيليه ليس فقط
في الايام القليله الماضيه بل منذ انطلاق
مفاوضات السلام في تموز
2013 الماضي تموز اب 2013 الماضيه التي
حددت ب 19 اشهر فمنذ تلك اللحظه وحقيقه
اسرائيل تصاعد وتصعد بالاستيطان الاستيطان
استشر كما لم يكن
في السابق على الاطلاق حوالي 15 الف وحده
سكنيه انبنت خلال المفاوضات وبالتالي
اسرائيل دائما تستفيد من هذه القضايا
تستفيد من عمليه التفاوض كي تنفذ مشروعها
الاول والاساسي وهو الاستيطان وهو حقيقه
سرق والسطر على الممتلكات الفلسطينيه
وحتى
ينكر للفلسطينيين قيام دولتهم وقيام
استقلالهم على ارضهم حتى لا يقرب بان هذه
الارض محتلفه ما نراه الان في القدس او في
الضفه الغربيه بشكل كامل هو جزء من
الاستيطان المنهج الذي تعارضه الولايات
المتحده خاصه وانها باستمرار تلزم نفسها
بحل الدولتين وتقول ان تغيير الحقائق على
الارض هذا شيء غير مرغوب فيه ومن ثم تعود
وتقول ان السبيل لذلك هو المفاوضات
المباشره ولكن في كل مره اسرائيل هي تلقي
بعرض الحائط بالمواقف الامريكيه وبالحبايه
الامريكيه في النهايه اسرائيل دوله محميه
امريكيه تعتمد عليها من ناحيه الامن
والسلاح والاموال والى اخره وفي الوقت
نفسه
الرئيس وزراء اسرائيل واسرائيل بشكل عام
تتصرف وكانها هي الحليف الاكبر في هذه في
هذا التحالف فاذا هناك انزعاج وانزعاج
حقيقي والولايات المتحده قد تجد نفسها مضط
الى بلوره خطتها هي نفسها لحل هذا الاشكال
ووقف الاستيطان الذي يبدو انه اسرائيل
يعني لديها شهيه كبيره للاستمرار به عندما
نتحدث ايضا عن الاجراءات الاسرائيليه في
القدس
سيد باردو
بالطبع من وجهه النظر القانون الدولي
ومنوجات النظر اغلب الدول في العالم
تقريبا شبه اجماع على ان وضعيه القدس
الشرقيه هي اراضي محتله بتقديرك لماذا لا
تتصرف اسرائيل وتاخذ بالاعتبار هذا هذا
هذه النقطه المهمه وهي تعلن هذه السلسله
من الاجراءات خاصه موضوع القبضه الامنيه
والاجراءات الامنيه الاستثنائيه في القدس
مكانه القدس مساله اللاجئين الفلسطينيين
الحدود وعدد اخر من
المواضيع يجب وهناك اتفاقات دوليه ان يتم
التوصل الى حلول بالنسبه لها في اطار
التفاوض المباشر بين اسرائيل والفلسطينيين
اما فيما يتعلق ببناء الوحدات السكنيه
فعلينا ناخذ بالنظر لاعتبار بان سكان
اسرائيل هم مشردين لاجئين
ويجب اقامه وحدات سكنيه ليس فقط في القوت
وانما ايضا في بيروت ودمشق والاردن وفتح
ايضا ابواب
اماكن الحجازيه لزياره اليهود
والمسيحيين وغيرهم في الشرق الاوسط هناك
الكثير من الاقليات يتم ذبحهم اذا كانوا
ايزاديين اذا كانوا
هذا ليس موضوعنا الدكتور
هذا ليس موضوعنا هذا ليس موضوعنا هذا
هو الموضوع لو كان موضوعنا عن اليازيين لو
كان موضوعنا عن اليزيديين
اسمح لي دكتور
ارجوك ارجوك لو كان موضوعنا عن اليزيديين
او الاقليات اهلا وسهلا بك في حلقه اخرى
الحلقه هذه اسمح لي دكتور اسمح لي دكتور
تريد
ان لا تريد ان تهرب من الحديث عن القدس
تتحدث عن اليزيديين
ارجوك دكتور ارجوك حلقتنا حلقتنا واضحه
لا موضوعنا بالطبع انت اتيت الى حلقه
لنتحدث عن الممارسات الاسرائيليه في القدس
نحن انتم لا تسمحون لنا ببناء بيوت يا
سيدي لا نت
هذا مش موضوعنا هذا مش موضوعنا في حلقه
اخرى بحول الله لما تاتي عن موضوع
الاقليات وتكون ضيف اهلا وسهلا تكلم بيك
الان نتحدث عن وضع معين في القدس وعن
اجراءات معينه في القدس موضوع اللي يزيدين
والاقليات وربما في في حلقه اخرى اذا اسمح
لي هذا هذا ابتعاد عن الموضوع ومحاوله
لتحريف النقاش اسال الدكتور مصطفى سواق
برايك لماذا لا تعتبر اسرائيل ولا تعتد
اطلاقا بايه حديث دولي عن القدس وضروره
المحافظه على الوضع القائم فيها وعدم
السماح لاسرائيل باي تغييرات
يعني هو اسرائيل تحاول ان تفرض نظريه هي
تؤمن بها بان القدس هي المدينه الموحده
وهي عاصمه دوله اسرائيل المزعومه وهذا هي
المغالطه الكبيره التي يحاول ايضا البعض
التسوق معها مدينه القدس وفق القانون
الدولي وفق كل المواثيق الدوليه هي مدينه
محتله من قبل الاحتلال عام 67 عندما قام
بعدوانه على الاراضي الفلسطينيه والاراضي
العربيه وتم الاستيلاء على مدينه القدس
بالقوه بعد ارتكاب مجازر بحق الشعب
الفلسطيني هذه هي الحقيقه التي يحاول
اليهود الخروج منها او عدم الاعتراف بها
لكي يمارسوا عمليات الاستيطان باريحيه
كامله وكان القدس هي جزء من كيانهم الذي
انشئ على حساب الشعب الفلسطيني ولا حساب
الارض الفلسطينيه ولذلك هم يحاولون فرض
هذه الرؤيه من اجل ان لا يحاسبوا على ما
يقومون به من عمليات استيطان اساسا تخالف
كل القوانين وتخالف كل المواثيق وتخالف
حتى مواقف الدول حتى الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه
بعد اذنك على ذكر هذه المحاسبه نريد ان
نعرف بعد الفاصل طبيعه اي جهود دوليه يمكن
ان تبدا لوضع حد لما يجري الان في القدس
المحتله وهذا التصعيد من قبل اسرائيل خاصه
وان هناك انسداد كامل في مساعي التسويه
والمفاوضات في الوقت الحالي لنا عوده نرجو
ان تبقوا معنا
اهلا بكم من جديد مازلتم معنا في هذه
الحلقه التي نتناول فيها ابعاد المواجهات
بين الفلسطينيين وقوات الاحتلال في القدس
على خلفيه الاجراء الاجراءات الاسرائيليه
الاخيره في الحرم القدسيه الشريف سيد سعيد
عريقات قبل الفاصل كنت تشير الى انزعاج
امريكي تجاه ما يجري في القدس هناك ايضا
انزعاج اوروبي هناك ايضا مواقف
لمجلس حقوق الانسان في جناف هناك جلسه
لمجلس الامن الدولي حول الاستيطان هناك
ايضا تغير في المزاج الاوروبي مع اعتراف
دوله السويد دوله فلسطين هل تعتقد بان
هناك ربما مناخ دولي يمكن الان ان يساعد
على التحرك لوضع حد لما يجري
بكل تاكيد انا اعتقد ان العالم حقيقه
سائمه بهذا الغطرسه الاسرائيليه
والتصرف كدوله مارقه هي حقيقه الدوله
المارقه بامتياز في العالم
شنت حرب وحشيه على مواطنين ابرياء في غزه
بمعظمهم ودمرت غزه هي التي تقوم
بالاستيطان هي التي تلقي بعرض الحائط
بكافه القرارات قرارات الشرعيه الدوليه
فاذا العالم يرى ما يجري في الاراضي
المحتله هذا العالم الذي اكد مره تلو
الاخرى ان هذه اراد محتله وليس اراضي
ديسبيوتد كما يقولون
في في طبيعتها فاذا هناك
متنازع عليها هي ليست ارض متنازع عليها
فالعالم يريد ان يرى حل لهذه القضيه لان
هذه القضيه او هذا الصراع هو صراع يؤثر
على العالم ككل
الولايات المتحده تحاول التعامل مع هذا
الصراع منذ عقود وتفشل كل مره حقيقه بسبب
الموقف الاسرائيلي الذي لديه مشروع واحد
وهو مشروع الاستيطان اسرائيل تستعمل البعد
الديني ولكن في حقيقه الامر هي تريد ان
تسيطر وان تصدر على كافه الاراضي
الفلسطينيه وتريد نهايه الفلسطينيين وتريد
انكار حق قيامه دولتهم على ارضهم
التاريخيه فاذا العالم
ينفذ وبالتالي لابد من التعامل مع هذا
الامر اسرائيل لا يردعها رادع
ولا لا تستمع لا لصديق ولا
لمناوئ وبالتالي اعتقد ان العالم وصل الى
مرحله على الاقل ان يتخذ الموقف الاخلاقي
ويقول علينا ان نكمل الشق الذي تم من
خلاله الاعتراف باسرائيل وقيام دوله
اسرائيل عام 47 و48 الشق الاخر من ذلك هو
قيام دوله فلسطين وبالتالي ما هي الواجبات
الدوليه الواجبات الدوليه هي بالبدء
بالاعتراف بحق هذا الشاب حقه التاريخي في
ان يقيم دولته على ارض التاريخيه
حل قضيه اللاجئين والتنفيذ حق العوده لان
هناك قرار دولي في ذلك ووقف هذا الاستيطان
ووقت هذا هذه الغطرسه وهذه الاعتدالات حتى
يعني بعد اذنك حتى من يتابع بعد اذنك نعم
بعدين حتى من يتابع
افتتاحيات الصح الاسرائيليه وبعض الكتاب
الاسرائيليين وهنا اسال الدكتور باردو حتى
من يتابع بعض الكتابات الاسرائيليه يقرا
بان هناك
استياء من كثير من المعلقين والمحللين
الاسرائيليين على ان اسرائيل الان باتت
دوله شبهه منبوذه وتسير على طريق جنوب
افريقيا تقريبا ايام التمييز العنصري
للولايات المتحده مرتاحه لها للمجتمع
الدولي لاوروبا تقريبا تكون دون صديق او
حليف الان الى متى يمكن لاسرائيل ان تظل
هكذا متعنته في مواجهه
استياء دوله عام من سياساتها
لا العكس الصحيح اسرائيل
العالميه اليوم احسن مما كان في في الماضي
لان تكنولوجيات الاسرائيليه ضروريه اليوم
للجميع الدول الكبرى التي تتنافس مع بعضها
البعض مثلا جميع الحواسيب عندكم في
الاستوديو هم من تكنولوجيا اسرائيليه ولكن
اذا عدنا الى مساله مدينه القدس اللهم
اللهم دكتور اللهم دكتور اللهم انت اللهم
انت وردت هذه التجهيزات انا لا علم لي بان
هذه التجهيزات الاسرائيليه اذا كنت انت
وردت هذه التجهيزات للجزيره انا لا علمي
على كل انا لا اتحدث مره اخرى انا لا
اتحدث انا لا اتحدث عن التكنولوجيا انا لا
اتحدث عن التكنولوجيا اسرائيل دوله متطوره
ولا تكنولوجيا ومن تقريبا ترتيبها الخامس
في العالم من حيث التكنولوجيا هذا لا جدال
فيه لكن هذا لكن هذا لا يعني انها دوله لا
يعني انها ليست دوله محتله او ليست دوله
تتعامل بعنصريه تكنولوجيا ترتيبها تقريبا
الخامس لكن هذا لا علاقه له بالسياسه
اشكرك على هذا التعليق ولكن
سياسه تفضل
اريد ان اتفضل
اذا عدنا الى مدينه القدس السواد الاعظم
من السكان المدينه وانا اعيش في مدينه
القدس وانا كمان زرت
بزياره بالقرب من الحرم في ليله القدر
لمشاركه اصدقائي
المسلمين السواد الاعظمي السكان القدس
يريدون ان تكون مدينه القدس مدينه موحده
مع ذلك هناك
البرنامج التعليمي الفلسطيني في الاجزاء
الفلسطينيه والبرنامج المستقل المتدين لدى
الحاقدين والبرنامج الاسرائيلي فهي مدينه
لها فيها
اقليات كثيره ولا يمكن
لافراد مثل الزميل من غزه ونحن نعلم ان
الميثاق ميثاق حركه حماس يدوي لقتل جميع
اليهود في العالم
هذه مره اخرى هذه مره اخرى
هذا تعبير غير دقيق وحلقتنا وحلقتنا لا
ليست عن حماس اسمح لي ساسال ساسال السيد
مصطفى سواف في نهايه الحلقه سؤال للسيد
مصطفى سواف والسيد سعيد عريقات وهو نفس
السؤال لان القضيه واضحه انا الدكتور
باردو للاسف يحرف النقاش عن عن مساره اريد
ان نعرف من سيد مصطفى سواف ما طبيعه
الاجراءات التي يمكن للمجتمع الدولي ان
ياخذها بشكل جدي لوضع حد لهذا النوع من
السياسات الاسرائيليه الان خاصه في القدس
المجتمع الدولي الذي يتحرك الان ضد ما
يسمى بداعش يجب عليه ان يتحرك بنفس
المستوى ضد الاجراءات الاسرائيليه لانها
اخطر مما يقوم به داعش اسرائيل قتلت في 51
يوم اكثر من 2000 فلسطيني ودمرت عشرات
الالاف من البيوت هذا العالم الان يقف
بشكل خجول امام الاجراءات الاسرائيليه هذه
الاجراءات ربما تكون افضل مما كانت عليه
في السابق ولكنها لا ترقى الى مستوى وضع
حد للجرائم المرتكبه من قبل الاحتلال ومن
قبل المستوطنين ومن قبل كل المتطرفين لانه
هذا الذي يتحدث عن وجوده في مدينه القدس
هو متطرف جاء واحتل ارض فلسطينيه وطرد
اهلها عنها لذلك لابد ان يتحرك المجتمع
الدولي في الاتجاه الصحيح حتى يضع حدا
لهذه الجرائم المرتكبه من قبل الاحتلال
بحق القدس وبحق كل الاتجاه الذي تدعو اليه
سيد مصطفى
صحيح نرى السيد سعيد عريقه كيف يراه يمكن
ان يكون بالفعل اتجاه صحيح
بكل تاكيد هناك الكثير من الاجراءات
بامكان المجتمع الدولي اتخاذها على سبيل
المثال الولايات المتحده موجود في القانون
ان الاستيطان هو غير شرعي هذا موجود
قانونا على الولايات المتحده ان تنفذ
قوانينها ايضا في قضيه ضمانات العقود على
سبيل المثال ضمانات القروض التي تعطيها
الولايات المتحده لاسرائيل بمليارات
الدولارات
ضيفك يتحدث عن التكنولوجيا وهذه
التكنولوجيا كلها امريكيه هناك
في القانون في قانون
الضمان القروض اذا ذهب الى المستوطنات ولو
دولار واحد الولايات المتحده تختضح هذا
الدولار وتاخذه مره اخرى فما عليها الا ان
تنفذ هذه القوانين واعتقد انها ستعود
وتزور هذه القوانين التي تمتلكها هي كذلك
المجتمع الدولي الذي طالما وقر ان هذه
الارض هي محتله عليه ان ينفذ ذلك بات خاذ
معايير واجراءات جديده شكرا لك الكاتب
المتخصص في السياسه الخارجيه الامريكيه
السيد سعيد عريقات كنت معنا من واشنطن
شكرا لضيفنا من القدس دكتور امداد بارد
والسد الدراسات الشرق الاوسطيه في الجامعه
العبريه وشكرا ايضا لضيفنا من غزه الكاتب
والمحلل السياسي مصطفى السواق